all right gentlemen and ladies um
I'd like to call this meeting
of the
uh
Commission on worldwide combined
reporting for unitary businesses under
so
everybody who has been participating
actively is here with the exception of
Senator Murphy who I hope will be able
to join us um and I know he is staying a
price of everything even though he's got
a a busy schedule that required him to
leave a bit early last last week
I'd like to just review where we're at
in the process and what our objectives
are for today
and for winding up over the next several
weeks
so much of this has been said but uh
I think we had a very productive hearing
last week and I'm going to review the
bidding in terms of who we've heard from
um
and so my objective for today is that at
the very least
everything we have uh before us both in
terms of verbal testimony as well as
written submissions that have been
circulated
is on the table discussed uh questions
uh
um are are all you know surface and if
there's any additional information that
we're trying to seek in order to get
ourselves ready for writing you know a
report hopefully a fairly definitive
report
then let's identify those today and we
can have a few follow-throughs
I think there could be a little bit of
that I don't expect that there will be
very much
so
at the least we know what's on the table
and we fleshed it out
um
if we're in a position to see you know
where the chips are falling and where
our views are I think it would be
constructive before the end of this
session to know where we're headed to
have the opinion of each of us and
understand whether we have
um Unity a unified view or whether we're
preparing to have a majority and a
Minority Report
and
I think the most optimistic scenario is
that we leave here today in a position
to say who's drafting what and let that
that one or two people get going
so on October 17th we'll meet again at
10 A.M
and if the optimistic scenario is
underway we should be able to be
reviewing a draft report
and make modifications changes
suggestions and see whether you know how
close are we to actually having
something that uh
that we consider a finished product
I I think it would be desirable if we're
at that point on the 17th and don't need
to physically meet again it is possible
to do some editing refinements of the
report and sign offs without having to
get together
and of course we have two different
deadlines so to speak one is the
the formal deadline of November 1st to
file a final report
at which point this commission goes out
of business and the second is as a
practical matter to assist the house
Ways and Means Committee and evaluating
HB 121 representative Schamberg's bill
on the subject of combined worldwide
reporting
which the ways and means has retained
and has to file their report to the full
house no later than November 17th and I
believe it's the intention of the
chairman and the vice chair to to do
that in the first week of November so
I think this is all realistic but it
means we've got to stay on our toes
um
so between our Clerk and our research
assistant Gen4
I want to make sure that uh
as we go ahead with the preparation of
the report and and final submission that
we have a complete record
of um all whom we've heard from
um
to get a good cross section
I think that uh both the pros and the
cons have been well represented
so we have we have Mr opal and his uh
two colleagues I see Mr Garros here
again today who spoke in favor
we have uh Miss Beeson and Mr pasetsky
from the
um Global business Alliance who spoke in
opposition
uh
professor hellerstein gave us the
benefit of a fairly neutral account that
I think was extremely good on the
history
and provides great context
um both Mr bucks
formerly of the Montana Department of
Revenue and Professor Shamsky encouraged
uh
uh approval of this of this proposal
and Carl frieden of cost
spoke against it
and then of course the dra without
taking a position gave us some sense of
what the challenges of implementation
might be
in addition
the the record will include various
articles from tax notes Supreme Court
decisions
in the Barclay and caterpillar cases
some briefs supplied by Mr Garr did I
say tax notes articles some submissions
from the NTU the national taxpayers
Union and
Jordan was the only one called the
taxpayer Foundation
tax Foundation tax Foundation
um and uh those two NTU and tax
Foundation were opposed to the idea
so I will admit that with the very large
amount of information that's been sent
to us I've probably read 75 80 percent
of it then so I still have more to read
and I would strongly encourage members
to read as much as they can but it's a
lot and I suspect we'll all get you know
to different degrees of completeness
so we have quite a record and I I'm not
familiar yet with the procedure but I
want to make sure between our Clerk and
Gen 4 that everything that's been
circulated becomes a formal part of the
permanent record of the commission
I went upstairs and saw Jen this morning
and she says thank you for all those
things that were sent to her she is
making all the physical copies that will
go into all this will go into one final
binder
so she's on top of it okay very good so
let's see with with that introduction is
there any member who would like to say
anything before we get ready to queue up
a discussion on the issues merits yes
representative Hillary I would like some
clarification because the apparently the
Minnesota
house passed this but I'm not sure if
the Senate killed it or if it was killed
by veto and I'm not sure why it didn't
go into law
and I would like some clarification on
that if somebody can help
all I can say is if
the Senate did not pass on it it did not
get legal it was just
died a agonizing death
to my internship passed the Minnesota
house and died in the South one section
could have been ways and means but it
died
before it could have been on the four
okay so that's a it's a good question
has just gone through the same procedure
yeah
officially died also probably on the
form so the question was how it was the
okay I'm gonna ask Jen if she can help
to clarify what the final disposition
and in both Minnesota and Maine was
and
to a degree what you know what was the
point at which it fell
okay
okay other general questions whether
it's process or information we need Mr
Kennedy
um
I'm just curious relative to uh you know
majority and Minority Report
um is it possible and I'm thinking
because of the information that was
provided and because of the newness
relative to the taxation of guilty in
New Hampshire and the dra not having
sufficient information to relay how that
might affect
the taxation of foreign entities
that more time might be needed for this
commission to get data say in another
year and is it possible that instead of
issuing a report that we would simply
indicate that additional time was needed
or would that simply not be what comes
out of this and and that uh
there would be another commission that
would be appointed in another year
okay the good questions
um
our charge and our time limit and our
duty to report are established in the
law that was passed in 2022
and they stand you know speak for
themselves and can't be changed
so we will file a report and that report
we're not under an obligation to reach a
unified position we're also actually not
under an obligation to make a clear
recommendation for or against we may
choose to but our report I think should
represent our best understanding of the
facts and the situation at this time
we as we understand it so equivocating
explaining and identifying what are
unknowns
indicating the reason for uncertainty
certainly can be a a significant part of
the report
but dodging not reporting are not
options and extending our own life is
not an option it's always possible that
the legislature could decide to create a
new commission or or do something to
extend the life of the study it may be
that the action now switches to the
House and Senate Ways and Means
committees
but so I I would just say we'll make the
best record that we can and identify
what do we think
would if we had known X Y and Z that
might have made our report
more definitive
so I think you know we disclose the
weaknesses as well
okay good morning Senator Murphy I just
uh We've we've just opened done an
introduction and a review of the
information that's before us both those
uh who testified
as well as
the written information so there's a
huge amount that's been circulated and
and
it's kind of overwhelming I did get the
link to the huge file this morning or
yesterday so thank you very much right
right so you know we're all at a
different place as far as what we've
been able to fully absorb so far and and
everything that's been circulated will
be part of the commission's record
and the purpose today then is to
evaluate what we have in front of us and
decide where we're going
so are there any other comments or
okay I would along the lines of what Mr
Kennedy just asked
um
I would Echo
's question it would be great if we were
able to quantify how much tax revenue
State of New Hampshire
has taken in in recent years
as a result of the guilty tax
and it would be great to identify or
quantify how much has been taken in as a
result of the taxation of foreign
dividends
those are two sources of funds that
impart tax that
they tax some degree of foreign Revenue
foreign Source revenue and so they they
might be viewed as
an offset against what an advocate of
the combined worldwide reporting might
expect to gain
I've had a conversation with Keane
already I think that we have only a very
limited
ability to quantify those but he's going
to look into those so whatever you can
find
or an explanation of what you can't find
would be great in the coming days so
that it can be baked into the cake by
you know before October 17th okay
so that's one line of inquiry
I think another line of inquiry is
to what extent can we delineate
the portion of our business profits tax
that are derived from multinationals
sub a
U.S based multinationals sub B foreign
based multinationals
perhaps a different way of saying that
is
to what extent are our tax revenues
derived from filers Who currently use
and I don't think that really gets us
anywhere near an idea for you know what
this proposal if it was enacted would
raise I don't think it gets there at all
but at least it gives us some sense of
what portion of our tax base
our multinationals in either the
home-based or the foreign-based context
so those those would be my two requests
and I I
anticipate there's some real limits on
your giving us a good good data but
good morning so definitely we'll uh look
into getting that information
um so in regards to the the revenue from
the guilty income I believe I explained
it in a previous meeting that currently
we do not have the capability to um
which we do have but then we we have not
tracked the the amount of guilty income
that is reported on the uh on the New
Hampshire returns
um that is not
um
mapped that line specific line actually
how we would get how we would propose to
get to that number is actually probably
to back into that number because that
guilty income is something that's
already reported on a federal return and
it flows into the New Hampshire return
and what is reported on the New
Hampshire return that kind of separate
from the federal return is just to allow
that 50 deduction on the guilty income
and um so the only way for us to
currently back into that number is to
potentially
get that 50 number and then
multiply that by two
um currently the uh those that form oh
that particular line on that form is not
mapped onto the system
so mapping that would only give us
information
prospectively as opposed to information
what that was submitted in the past so I
I doubt that we will be able to come up
with any kind of um
figure that would be useful for the the
report for for the guilty income but I
will definitely have a look into
um for the foreign dividends most likely
we might be able to get that information
and then as for the water's edge filing
um yes so the the multinationals would
be submitting a Waters Edge return and
in for New Hampshire purposes but also
just bear in mind that Water's Edge
return also includes filers who may not
be multinational but but do file combine
return so they are potentially
U.S uh just limited to the U.S
um
I guess conducting business in the U.S
but then they have multi-jurisdictional
so that's a very important Point you're
making because the water's edge is
utilized by any multi-state company that
has to a portion across States that's
correct
um knowing how many follow the water's
age does not actually lead us to the
answer of which ones are multinational
and would potentially
take advantage of right we can try to
look into that to see if we can um
dig into our system see if there's any
way for us to tell any okay which one
exactly is a multinational versus a U.S
company or solely a U.S company just
filing a Water's Edge return we can try
to look into that and see if we can come
up with with those statistics
okay
thank you for undertaking that
now it occurs to me also before we get
into the merits I've just been handed to
memos this morning which I believe we
all have and since we haven't had a
chance to read them yet one is from Keen
follow-up to the various questions that
arose last week the other one is from
the New Hampshire Society of CPAs that's
come from Matt
um I'm going to ask each of you if you
will just quickly walk us through this
so that we have the gist of what you've
got here without having to All Pause and
sure uh the email uh this handout that I
provided this morning is the email that
I sent out this morning
um
answering the two questions that was
posed to the dra one is to provide a
brief description of how potentially
that the audit process would change if
we were moving from a uh what is Edge
combined filing to a worldwide combined
filing and then the other question is
what would be what was the uh the fiscal
impact uh back in 1986 when we converted
from the awards from the worldwide fall
into the Waters Edge filing system
I sort of answered the first one is uh
in terms of the audit process we do not
see a huge change in the audit process
but as what Fred uh the uh the director
of our multi uh director of audit
testified last week is that it's just
more of um everything so be more
the volume will be higher in terms of
the documentation that needs to be
reviewed
um and uh potentially more returns
coming in in the
analysis potentially could be different
because it's going to be a worldwide
analysis versus a water station analysis
um and then also there could be
potential um hurdles
um that we could see in the
performing a a worldwide audit uh and
we've listed that out here
um in terms of currency exchange rates
the uh what's the International
Accounting and text reporting methods
sort of reconciling that to to the U.S
system and then the language barrier
um and then we potentially could also
see um field visits to International
locations where the rec the books or the
key personnel are located
for the second
second piece second answer uh this the
question the answer to the second
question is uh for the
the revenue
change from
worldwide to Water's Edge so when I did
the research and saw that um we try to
perform a fiscal impact uh fiscal note
back then and we were not able to really
calculate anything specific because when
when we were in worldwide the um the
information is collected is different
than what would have been for Water's
Edge because worldwide
um the the probably the the denominator
will be on a worldwide basis we wouldn't
have
distinguish okay what is what would have
been if it was the water's edge
um and then similarly probably the the
tax base the income the the revenue uh
the uh the taxable income from the
federal side
um will probably be a combination of
of worldwide income versus what would
have been for uh New Hampshire or
Water's Edge but we did
provide the um
the business profits tax and business
Enterprise tax revenue for the fiscal
years getting back from 1980 to 1991.
and hopefully that would be some
help to the commission as you can see
um
for fiscal year 1986
um the well you'll see that um
so bear in mind this is fiscal year
Revenue so fiscal year revenue is means
that it's Revenue collected between July
1 and June 30th and then it would also
be for any of the returns that been
submitted during that period so it could
be a combination of
um
different tax years returns from
different textures that fell into that
was submitted and paid so is it probable
that the act of the
enacting the repeal of worldwide
combined reporting in 1986 probably
didn't take effect
until the 87 or 88 fiscal yeah
so I I do see a significant jump from
110 to 150 and 87 do you think we should
read anything into that
um
we don't have much more to
um to provide by just the speculate yeah
that potentially could be when we change
from um from water from worldwide to
Water's Edge
yes representative Valerie
I'm sorry that's right
not enough coffee
the uh
chart is very interesting although it
seems to be showing a decrease coming
down from
1989. it would be interesting to see
what happens from 91 going forward when
we again had another
the both of the committee Ways and Means
and for this particular report when we
have a different type of tax form with a
reduced business tax and an increase in
revenues from that which have been at
least reading the charts that dra puts
out you guys put out seems to be
increasing with revenues with the
decreased tax rate
so that
that would be something I would like to
also see added into this because it
would help balance in my mind
how
the tax policy affects our business
taxes
um this this and I also don't understand
why it went down and do you have any
insight into that from non-89 down well
89 down that's that's you know 20 000 or
20 million drop in one year is
interesting
I wonder if it has something to do with
the fact that there was a recession with
the Iraq War so yes so the
I can't provide much more than that but
then that's as uh representative
spilsbury is saying
this fiscal year Revenue analysis
um
it's not just what we change in New
Hampshire but
um because our revenue is the the
calculation of new hash taxes runs off
from the federal calculation so uh
whatever the the companies uh feeling
from the federal side
would be reflected on the New Hampshire
return as well so any kind of national
activity that maybe if there's some kind
of Boom in the National economy
creating
um
huge revenues for the the taxpayers that
probably will will trickle down to the
New Hampshire returns as well and the
I don't know what this would tell us but
if it's not a lot of work I assume it's
information readily available it is I
think would be very interesting to
extend this chart from the first
implementation of the BPT which I think
was 1970. two current date
again I don't know what it would tell us
but since it's so readily available
perhaps you can have that done yes sure
I believe that is all these assignments
no no it's fine but this one is this one
is going to be too challenging because I
believe all this information is on our
annual report already probably yeah
so you're helping us by by Framing it
and putting it in front of our eyes yep
thank you yes
I presume it wouldn't be too challenging
I wasn't doing taxes back in those years
could you kind of identify what the tax
rates were
um and also
um include I don't know bet was I don't
know when bet was created but
um but I'd be curious to see if there
were changes in the rate the rates were
more or less or if they changed over
those years to see how that might have
affected sure the total yep but so but
bear in mind as well this is fiscal year
Revenue those tax rate changes would be
tax unit sure yeah
great so that sounds very constructive
so I'm envisioning a multi-column chart
with the b p t the BET broken out and
then aggregated and the rate that's is
it uh we won't be able to break out the
BPD and the BET Revenue will be a
combined pptm bed Revenue
um because that's what we've been
collecting the data so far
right
um and then um so it will be a a similar
chart to this with the fiscal year and
the bpdn BET tax revenue and then on the
site potentially because it will be
impossible to superimpose the tax rate
change on a fiscal year basis so the
notes on the first the tax rate change
would be as a note to to the chart
okay right that sounds helpful though
okay
yes representative schampert thank you
Mr chairman going back to your
King going back to your original paper
here numbers one through eight
uh taxpayer selection all the way to
closure
can
audits be done by reporting through the
um have our audit director chiming on
that but then I'll potentially say that
um we could but then it depends on how
much we want to
um can rely on that information I
suppose I I did specifically ask Mr Cool
broth to attend today because I
anticipated questions would arise that
he could help us with so if you I'll
who said bud
Fred cool broth director of audit for
the record uh and thanks to the
commission again for having me here so
to to answer your question
representative
I do Envision some worldwide worldwide
audits occurring
at the
domestic offices of these companies
uh that the that determination
would be based off of
who the taxpayer is what their worldwide
operations look like and thus who we can
be expected to meet and what documents
we can be expected to find
at their domestic offices their domestic
headquarters so
if it's reasonable based on the
competition the composition of the
taxpayer if it's reasonable that uh
the hosting the audit domestically
would yield the type of information we
would want provided
then we would do it there just like
under a Water's Edge audit where we
would send field Auditors to their
domestic offices interview folks there
and uh
start the document production process at
their local offices
oh
Mr well then
let me ask this
can the Revenue Agency adopt rules
requiring the maintenance and
availability for audit of taxpayer
information relevant to the conduct of
worldwide tax auditing I mean could all
that information you need
to ever do a worldwide audit be sent to
that subsidiary office for you to
undertake without having to
use uh
you know you mentioned language you
mentioned I can't the dra set their own
rules or regulations yep so
we can adopt that rule
to the extent taxpayers will comply with
it would be to be determined we have
plenty of rules now that we've adopted
that taxpayers don't comply with
um
the challenges we would run into even
with perfect
compliance with that and
there would be both unintentional and
potentially intentional non-compliance
with that
um but the the challenges there would be
we'd get pushback for certain types of
Records most of this stuff can be
provided electronically and we we do
receive the bulk of our records
through electronic transmittal
some and I think Dan Buck's testified to
this
during the last commission meeting I
think maybe Keynes mentioned this but at
any rate there are certain
certain documents that companies
tend not to or sometimes do not preserve
completely in digital form
um
but the
the
main drawback to this to that approach
would be
we still would be missing
opportunity opportunities that we could
only
we would only have if we traveled to
their other foreign locations so
um
seeing where all of their records are
kept originally seeing
those operations interviewing those
people
so there would be limits there will be
limits on that approach but to to answer
your question we can adopt that rule
and there presumably would be some
amount of compliance with it I'm I don't
know that there would I am skeptical
can I ask
questions Keen
in the dra annual audits
from
um
I see their
there was
I don't these are fines
or are they
misapplied
uh ways that they deducted their money
you say no no you can't deduct this you
let me pass this can I pass this down to
Keynes for him to look at them all right
you do audits
and
you come up with like 36 million in
2022.
um
are these just
technical errors that people have
misinterpreted the the the domestic
uh
maybe they didn't think they were going
when you do those audits yes
I might have to pass this on to Fred so
this looks like a document that
tables that are that tracks the um from
fiscalia try 12 to 22
um the audit division report on our
annual report
um
potentially talks about something to do
with non-compliance of in a certain in a
certain manner I am not super familiar
with this but I'm going to pass it on to
correct
and the reason I ask it Keen I'm sorry
so just just to be clear and be the
purpose of today is a all-out discussion
so I'm going to keep it very informal
that this this should just be an
opportunity to flesh everything out sure
this um
what this looks like to me is not a
document that the audit division
prepared but it looks like
information that came from our annual
reports and was reorganized yeah so this
looks like our if I can just clarify
sure uh so the dollar column the the
second column next to the year next to
the fiscal year would be our total
assessment amounts
I believe this is tax only but there
might be interest in payments in these
amounts not sure that's super relevant
looks to be the number of a term of
returns that we adjusted as a result of
those audits
and to answer your question
these adjustments reflect a variety of
issues and
and frankly motivations behind the
non-compliance so
based on the size of the taxpayer and
their activity here they may be able to
allocate
um a certain amount of
resources and time to Preparing their
New Hampshire tax return and then
there's one taxpayer in particular I'm
thinking about I will obviously not name
them for confidentiality purposes but
there are
a very large multinational let's put it
that way they're active
everywhere not just domestically but
across the world and it's very obvious
when you look at their return that the
way they treat New Hampshire is we
really can't justify spending a lot of
time preparing this return just throw a
reasonable amount of money at them and
hope they go away and
um
historically our audit presence of this
taxpayer has been pretty light because
when you look at it it's like okay this
is very sloppy but
if we were to adjust this I don't know I
don't know where this would go they've
just done this at a very high level
obviously to make it through audit
selection and it looks reasonable on its
face so they don't get selected that
kind of behavior is on the one end of
the spectrum where
regardless of where the taxpayer lands
in their payment to New Hampshire and
their tax they just there's only so much
in terms of resources
and um that at the end of the day that
behavior might result in a big
adjustment from New Hampshire if we do
select them prod it
um
not this taxpayer but a different one if
we do select a taxpayer and it becomes
apparent that they've not spent a lot of
time with our rules they've misapplied
several Concepts there could be big
adjustments coming out of New Hampshire
and the size of that adjustment doesn't
necessarily reflect malintent on their
part it's just there's only so much
they've got a limited staff huge
presence and they just they do their
best
so sometimes that behavior means New
Hampshire it might actually
win in a sense because the taxpayer just
throws their hands up and throws what
the New Hampshire is a sizable amount of
money at us sometimes they under report
on the other end of the spectrum for
sure there are taxpayers reflected in
these numbers who engage in very
deliberate very often sophisticated tax
planning
and when we find that we bust that up
and we assess them and that can be large
but it's a spectrum with the one one
taxpayer on one end of the spectrum who
has underreported or underpaid their tax
through no Mal intent just ignorance and
lack of resources to the other end of
the spectrum where it's the result of
very deliberate tax planning and uh
with to to what extent that's just
aggressive positions that we Challenge
and we'll take an assessment on or we'll
issue an assessment on or to what extent
it even Rises beyond that to potential
criminal activity that's a different
discussion but both those
far-ranging sides of the spectrum and
then everything in between are
encompassed in these numbers here so the
size of the adjustment isn't always
reflective of what's going on in
people's heads
sometimes people will engage in really
sophisticated tax planning just to save
a buck and it's like I don't know what
the what the purpose of that is other
than you think you're getting one over
so if I'm interpreting you correctly
a filer who is trying to ease up on the
administrative burden might even round
up yes
that for sure happens we don't know
what's the prevailing practice but we
suspect that's at least one of the
scenarios that's one of the scenarios I
don't want to suggest that that's common
but it does happen it happens from some
games
well he's opened the door here and Mr
Kennedy opened the door last week on a
question I have here
guilty
only taxes U.S based multinational
companies
or all the applies to U.S based National
companies multinational or Mr Foley I'm
sorry
uh it does not apply to foreign National
does it not it only applies to U.S
taxpayers so U.S persons flow through
businesses which are taxes entities
obviously New Hampshire
USC Corps this this would flow up to
them so recall I gave that wonderful
explanation 10 we have to have a U.S
person which can be a flow through trust
what have you they have to own it
uh an interest in a foreign entity and
there's an aggregation but correct
so my follow-up question to you then
would be our U.S multinationals taxed
one-way and
all depends because you've got a giant
mixed bag right
um in that you could have a foreign
parented group that has a U.S entity
that from there has
Mexico and Canada underneath it or its
own subsidiary so it could be this chain
right
um but in general income earned by the
foreign parent or other foreign brother
sister companies right so if the US was
a subsidiary one that income's not going
to be subject in general to the U.S tax
base
if I can just make sure we're clear on
this
so it doesn't reach the foreign sourced
income but it does reach the U.S income
of a foreign entities U.S based
operation
correct
um I also want to just want to add that
if a foreign company
that conducts business activity in New
Hampshire
they will be subject to New Hampshire
taxes as well right next
oh yes so they if they have business
activity in New Hampshire
um and they will be filing as a
potentially like a like a separate
company
um other than you know so they would be
okay
good
um
the takeaway that I
have on the audit process is it's the
same process correct but it's the more
of everything and the complications
um
sometimes we legislators make very loose
analyzes when we try to understand
things but
uh I had the interesting experience of
working in the Netherlands for several
years
so I'm talking about personal income tax
which is distinct
and of course in personal income tax
what happens is you pay
the tax of the foreign country in which
you're working
and then you take a credit
and prepare U.S tax return I've always
done my own tax returns with the
exception of three years where I lived
in Europe
and just the experience of being an
individual
resulting in a tax return approximately
an inch thick that I couldn't understand
even when the tax accountant prepared it
and presented it to me and I'm saying I
couldn't understand it as someone who
has always prepared his own tax returns
otherwise
so extrapolating from that very loosely
I can only imagine
the complexity of
drawing in foreign Source Revenue
from potentially
dozens if not hundreds of different
entities
I also had the experience during that
time in the Netherlands
of being the general manager for
marketing of the largest shipping
company in the world for all of Europe
and Middle East so I was responsible for
34 countries
and I saw
um
what the challenges are of trying to
coordinate an Enterprise across 34
currencies this was before the euro
and not quite 34 but nearly as many
languages it's extraordinarily difficult
if we're trying to take the measure of
foreign earned income the Auditors at
least need to have the authority the
power if necessary
to look behind what they've been
presented that's the fundamental nature
of an audit
and those kinds of records that are
going to back up
what the foreign foreign Source revenue
of Affiliated units that have no direct
activity in the United States themselves
is not going to be held by
a subsidiary office in the United States
I can't even imagine the sweep of the
document request if you were to insist
that the U.S based subsidiary became the
repository for all of the records of the
various foreign Affiliates it's
unimaginable
you wouldn't even know
whether they had fulfilled the request
or not
and so I do think representative
Schaumburg that the audit
not everybody gets audited
some people get light audits some people
get intensive audits but in the event of
an intensive audit
being unable to go to the source
documents and make random searches uh
would completely handicap the audit in
my opinion
so I again I mean I'm just an individual
extrapolating out the amount of
complexity
involved is just staggering practically
indescribable
yes
yes my question is
just looking forward yep okay since
we're going to a single sales Factor all
right
uh
does the single sales Factor method
affect New Hampshire's taxation of
foreign dividends received by U.S
multinationals
uh since we dropped the old
method of payroll yes property yep
that's a great question so
the
foreign dividends get separate
apportionment
um from the rest of from from all other
income so as you know representative
Schamberg we take
um
we take all other sources of income into
the return We subject them to New
Hampshire apportionment and uh and that
gives us our apportionment percentage
the foreign dividends and income classes
like foreign dividends so guilty subpart
F but all of those all of those uh
income classes that some folks have
called foreign income
um
they get separate apportionment
treatment in the New Hampshire returns
so they get carved out of the general
apportionment they get their own
apportionment and
um
and then get added back in to the to the
whole into the hopper at the end of it
to generate your full New Hampshire tax
liability
in terms of how
uh excluding the other
um
the other apportionment the traditional
three factors payroll and property
taking them out of it
there are winners and losers to doing
that
um
some folks
with a lot of payroll and property here
benefit from or tend to stand to benefit
from single sales Factor because now
there's
those amounts no longer count towards
their apportionment folks who
traditionally benefited from not having
much of a footprint here in New
Hampshire with people payroll or people
they um they stand attended quote
unquote become losers I don't like that
term but they tend to see a potential
increase in their tax liability move
into single sales Factor we don't have
as you noted we've just gone there the
data is just coming in basically right
now so we don't really have a good sense
for how that shakes out
um
so we don't know whether that moved to
um to single sales factor in isolation
we don't know if that will be Revenue
neutral or Revenue positive for the
state we're still waiting to see what
what happens there and
um then to what extent you can
parse that out from all the other
factors that weigh in on their tax base
like Keane was talking about before a
broader economic trends
what else is going on at the federal
level that sort of thing it's it's I
leave that to key into the in his team
to decide what they can parse out from
that but
as a general matter I do think it's it's
a little early for us to be able to tell
how the
what the revenue impact is for moving to
single sales
thank you
so we I I'm sure we will come back to
the single sales Factor uh influences we
keep talking about it it
um anything else for This Moment On The
Memo from King Wong
if not
uh Matt Foley has also provided us
something that I haven't read yet not do
you want to just give us a quick
overview
sure it's this is from the society and
it's almost on the other side of of
Keene so this is more of the
practitioner perspective right so what
does this mean to us more work
um you know at the end of the day
um it was interesting I I forget to
report and I know it was back from the
80s but the 900 dollars to prepare one
of these worldwide returns I think was
floated
um and it's interesting to hear that we
wish right I mean that the issue would
be this this information currently
unless our client was to already be
filing uh voluntarily on a worldwide
basis in another jurisdiction we
actually have to go through and create a
separate federal return that we can kind
of group into the combined report to
submit to the state and put in the
combined report itself
some of the tax softwares are not the
kindest for some reason or another to
the New Hampshire combined reporting
it can require a lot of manual
adjustments a lot of frustrations there
um you know something that's commonly
worked through and then there's just
information gathering and kind of
looking at this depending on the number
of
foreign entities we're talking about
here and entities could take different
forms right so we've kind of focused on
guilty which applies to controlled
foreign corporations we could have
foreign Partnerships that we have to
consider in doing reporting for them we
could have foreign disregard identities
LLC equivalents and the like
um
so on and so forth that would have to be
analyzed kind of aggregated and put
through the return and we would need
more than just their you know Baseline
taxable income we would need
apportionment data State modifications
and the like so there's a lot of effort
that goes into that workable challenge
but a challenge nonetheless that should
just be highlighted a lot of the
impediments there have already been
discussed and they're similar to what
Keane mentioned some of them too
currency translation we could have tax
year gaps right so you know you could
have a calendar taxpayer here but they
adopt the UK of 331 or India which have
a non-physical non-calendar tax year in
general so dealing with issues like that
um the second Point here is one that I
kind of already referenced but
um or or maybe not who who would be in
this unitary group given that there's
not a specific identification based on
voter value on how we would determine
that that would take analysis and
education
um
uh the mandatory requirement is flagged
on the on the second page where the
other jurisdictions that have adopted
this
um there is a ability to opt out
um and then something I'm sure will be
brought up maybe this will spur it is
um you know the uncertainty regarding
whether this would lead to an increase
or decrease in New Hampshire business
tax revenues
um you know we've referenced kind of
things that are already in the tax base
and
being affected and what would be the
impact of this just highlighting that as
very good so I look forward to reading
this closely later on
what I see you're really largely hitting
on is the huge compliance burden
and the uncertainty of what
this scheme would actually yield
okay
um
so I'll I'll recognize any member uh as
you wish but uh let's let's just talk
about the things that are in front of us
and and I think this last
paragraph in
in your
memo Matt is worth focusing on
and I'm just going to read it out loud
it's unclear if mandatory worldwide
reporting would lead to an increase or a
decrease of New Hampshire business tax
revenues
including the income or loss of any
unitary foreign Affiliates would also
require including worldwide
apportionment data for those entities EG
worldwide sales
many foreign entities would not
apportion much if any activity to New
Hampshire but their total activity would
be included in the denominator
of the apportionment factors
so in theory while more income may be
captured in a worldwide tax return New
Hampshire apportionment could be
significantly diluted leading to a
decrease in New Hampshire business tax
revenues in many instances
I'd like to elaborate on this as I
understand it
and let's make this a point you know
focused conversation for for a bit
I was intrigued uh during our hearing
last week when representative Laurie
several times
postulated the hypothetical with a
shipyard in Scotland Shipyard in Denmark
I think the shipyards moved around and
the different uh
[Music]
and and so
I spent a lot of time
yeah I spent quite a bit of time
thinking about this over the past week
and
I thought
perhaps the most Salient thing that I
read on this subject during last week I
want to commend it to everybody even if
you don't get a chance to read
everything we've received
there were two uh write-ups from the tax
Foundation
um and and they took a position squarely
opposed to worldwide combined reporting
the headline of one of them was
something along the lines of let's leave
worldwide reporting in the 1980s where
it belongs so so their their Viewpoint
is clear but what was so striking to me
is I think
I don't want to overstate this but but
they just blew out of the water
the estimates
um
from itaps so Institute of Taxation and
had written an article that we received
a couple weeks ago titled a simple fix
and it made estimates
um of the total amount quote left on the
table
by virtue of the fact that none of the
50 states currently has the worldwide
combined reporting and then they
they
carved that out by state and they
assigned 177 million dollars to New
Hampshire
and that figure was mentioned by a
number of of our presenters last week
but the town the tax Foundation articles
absolutely demolish those estimates
there there is just simply so much flaw
in the assumptions in the methodology
that the figure is not credible and and
I guess I'm asserting this is my
personal opinion but that 177 million
dollar estimate is just simply not
supportable not workable
so I think it means that we remain in
the dark
in speculating what theoretically we
could gain
what the tax Foundation articles really
highlight
is that the fundamental flaw
is that we use formulary apportionment
so the United States IRS use our uses
arm's length separate entity filing
and it's only the states that have
decided to use combined reporting
albeit Limited at the water's edge
who are using the formulary
apportionment and and this has just been
highlighted minutes ago by
representative Schamberg and Mr Cool
broth we're only at the very very
beginning stages of having changed our
own apportionment from three factor to
single sales Factor
so here we are
with a business tax that as of this past
year
only looks at sales activity
so what does apportionment involve if we
have worldwide combined reporting it
it's just as Mr Foley's memo says here
it draws in all of this activity from
around the world
dramatically increasing the denominator
of a of an equation
but the activity being taxed is still
the sales in the state of New Hampshire
so the form the the tax foundation for
example uses a um
it it
postulates a situation where
you have a company that's doing uh 10
million dollars of business here and uh
90 million somewhere else and
you have
you know you bring in all of the
worldwide activity
but now your denominator explodes by 10
times
and you're basically taxing a lot of
activity that occurs somewhere else in
the world
under completely different circumstances
um under different rates
so I it it strikes me
um
that it distorts the equation
drastically
um that is Mr cool bro suggested a few
minutes ago there will be winners and
losers and and we won't know in advance
who's going to win and who's going to
lose and in fact the company that wins
this year might lose next year
the bottom line is it's going to depend
just like representative already
um suggested
on how their profits are doing
relatively speaking somewhere else
and if their profits were lower
Elsewhere on average or in the aggregate
than New Hampshire it will actually take
their
tax liability to New Hampshire down
and if their profits were greater
somewhere else it takes them up
but there's like no Rhyme or Reason and
the bottom line is when you look at what
the impact is it has nothing to do with
what's going on in New Hampshire
so I I think at the very least
this handicaps us and any of these
estimates
that have been made that we've seen
specifically the one by itep
um
this simply should not be considered too
flawed and and I would I would again I
would suggest you read those two
articles carefully not so much for the
the the
position
before their assessment of the math and
and
I sort of disagree with your
assessment not yours their assessment
because they provide no other
methodology how they performed their
assessment other than making General
generalized statements
uh
they have undertaken
as the methodology of the itep did in
2019 may not agree with the 177 and it
might be a little bit High
but someone
is not paying their full tax liability
and from the fact Coalition of uh out of
Washington DC
the Senate Bill uh 638 that was just
recently passed by the
the Senate the house and signed by the
president
requires the large multinationals began
country by country reporting of tax and
operational data to the Securities and
Exchange Commission
and the reason for this is that there
are investors
public reporting that is needed for
people to know on the boards and people
that are investing
what are is the true picture of your
I bring up
this 177 million may not be much
in the eyes of
certain people in New Hampshire
but when audits were done like in the
McDonald Corporation in France
they ended up having to pay 1.3 billion
dollars to settle their allegations of
transfer pricing and if you go to uh
the U.S Tax Court ruled that
in this country
that Coca-Cola used profit shifting to
underpay 3.3 billion dollars from 2007
to 2009.
and when they corrected the pricing
practices they resolve the company
facing a possible 14 billion in
additional liability
so
someone has done studies
this 177 million dollars
didn't they didn't show a methodology
they just took comparisons using
generalized terms I believe
I don't think they
well not not to to debate
your exact point but
tax Foundation did not undertake to make
so there was no methodology that they
proposed to follow that would allow for
an estimate in fact I think that they
probably I don't think they stated this
but I suspect if you ask them they would
say it's futile
what they did do though very effectively
is
undermine the methodology that leads to
the 177 million the 177 million is
so I I think that leaves us in a
predicament where
we have no way to estimate what the
consequences would be of implementing
worldwide combined reporting
it's an assumption that it would improve
New Hampshire's revenues
Mr chair
yes representative Oliver
in and I haven't done as deep a dive as
I would like into both of the articles
but from the surface the
the question that comes to mind is
you can only tax her entity whether it's
a human being or a corporate entity so
much before they just say
they give them throw up their hands and
say we're not going to play this game
if we cannot
reimburse our investors
and make it profitable for them to give
us money which is where their growth
comes from is from people investing in
it and getting a return on investment I
mean they even have an acronym for an
Roi
the question is
in my mind
doesn't
use a cliche over tax a business to the
point where it would just say
we've got some Nexus here uh territory
now
we're not going to have it anymore
I'm thinking of a a manufacturer over in
the uh Cheshire county that decided
rather than expanding in New Hampshire
not just because of taxes but for other
causes as well
um he was going there they that the
um
I know of another manufacturer over
towards the Seacoast area that did the
same thing we've had this happen Time
and Time and Time and Time and Time
Again
where people have left here
which brings me back to the question
that I asked to Wong earlier regarding
the amount of Revenue derived from our
tax base over time as to show when it
was low when it was high and what and
we've discussed uh with uh
Mr spilsberry the
I'm just a little concerned
that
we're getting into a position where
implementing this
May wind up
making the tax rate so high
that we get
an initial
plus an initial Rush of money coming in
and then saying well you got some Bank
of property on this street you got some
vacant property on that street you got
some vacant property over
in Litchfield right now which is going
to be housing
but uh
I just I'm really concerned about over
taxation of an individual because you
can you can and there's
plenty of economic proof to this you can
uh we can go back to the Laffer Curve
but you know you get more income here
than you do you get tax at 100 you get
zero Revenue you tax it zero percent you
get zero Revenue somewhere in between
there
there's a
may I respond they're just yes no yes I
don't think we're talking tax or I think
I don't think we're talking
tax rate I think we're talking your tax
liability are you
are you paying your fair share
of
what you have done in New Hampshire
because New Hampshire has provided
infrastructure it's provided you
know educated worker right that's where
I think that we should be looking tax
rates are things that we can debate in
ways and means
which
but this is more of a
what is the tax liberal is it a fair
tax policy you presently have that is
the question and
I think that we're
we wouldn't be in this if we and Senator
no uh
disrespect your
other side of the wall there but but
when they the wall in this room when
they went on the single sales Factor
without a study without putting it forth
for us to look at for the next four or
five years
to draw these numbers together and see
what is best do we walk away from our by
fruitcated uh approach of sales and
payroll and without any data
but the vast part that bothers me and if
we had that
we may not be pushing as hard on this
right now
I just got a feeling that single sales
affect our our Revenue because it's
sales within the state
going out so if I can pull a theme out
of both your comments
so there's no question even if it's
purely a theoretical uh point that
taxation at the margin at some point
will affect Behavior
Behavior can be affected in a whole
variety of ways one end of the spectrum
increasing your investment in New
Hampshire to the other end of the
spectrum pulling out of New Hampshire
all together
and a vast array of decisions in between
so the rate I agree
um that's one variable
in the equation of tax burden how you
define the base the tax base is really
what we're focused on in this commission
and that's another variable
but I think that representative ulery
has raised a question it's I suppose
ultimately a judgment call because we
again we don't have the ability to
quantify at what point
people will react adversely but
the fundamental purpose of Taxation is
to fund the basic needs of government
and that's a calibration and a judgment
call
that on the other side of the equation
requires policy decisions about how far
you go in taxation
and
soaking the taxpayer isn't always the
ideal
answer because you can easily find maybe
after the fact that you were Beyond uh
you know the point of diminishing
returns so I I do think that lurking
behind everything we discuss in this
Commission
is a judgment call on tax policy whether
trying to expand the base
in ways that are burdensome and complex
and unquantifiable and uncertain is a
wise idea
that certainly is you know what I'm
trying to distill virtually all of our
discussion down to
so others
Kennedy
um so relative to we we had a
presentation that the New Hampshire
taxation of guilty and I know keep kind
of coming back to this but is kind of
unique across the the states
and
when we discuss the guilty tax the
current taxation of guilty in New
Hampshire would presumably go away if we
went to a worldwide reporting so we have
a potentially known quantity in the
future
that'll tell us how much taxation is
being generated from the guilty income
that New Hampshire taxes versus the
unknown that would come from
the new apportionment where an increased
denominator that we don't know the
results
um the other item and I'd ask this
question is the concern that
um
local businesses are paying a higher
percentage of the base
is because in theory the
entities that have foreign corporations
are shifting that profit overseas by
means of taking a cost deduction here in
the U.S and the profit going and the
revenue going over to overseas and
whether or not the a potential
alternative approach would be to look at
the transfer pricing issues and having
New Hampshire address that specifically
for domestic companies that are paying
their foreign subsidiaries to reduce
their profit profit here in the in New
Hampshire which may be a s in my thought
would be a simpler means of addressing
those entities that are shifting their
profits overseas without converting
everybody to worldwide reporting with
the additional risk that we don't know
how that increased denominator is going
to affect the revenue stream
and on something of a slightly off-topic
item
though those still
kind of pertinent in terms of the bills
and I haven't I don't recall the bills
that are in place to move to worldwide
reporting but the my understanding is
the theory by moving to worldwide
reporting is that these entities that
are not just local but are foreign would
have a higher base and pay additional
taxes but I haven't yet heard how does
this save the the domestic smaller
businesses from paying more taxes is
there something in the bill that says if
we reach certain Revenue levels that the
business profit tax rate would go down
how how do local businesses domestic
businesses without foreign entities
actually receive a benefit if we were to
move to worldwide reporting and I'm
unclear as to how the the folks that
have said well we're paying too much but
I haven't seen how do they pay less if
we move to worldwide reporting how does
very good question
um
I was wondering and I respect completely
so I don't want to apply anything else
our Our Testimony a week ago from a
painting contractor left me wondering
how does doing this or not doing this
change the tax bill of a painting
contractor
you know maybe there is some level at
which a new york-based business is in
direct competition
with a foreign-based A supplier of the
same product or service and finds
himself in some kind of a direct
competitive disadvantage but from the
standpoint of smaller businesses that
are not directly competing I just don't
see that and from the standpoint of
mitigating their tax bill or changing
their own company's internal
um you know p l
I don't see it so I I think you've
raised an extremely good question I
representative Schamberg yes Mr chairman
it's more of
a moral issue here that we're saying
those that are in a BPT class those that
companies
some of those companies are able to use
accounting procedures for transfer
pricing that
the domestic companies
can't use and if you're in that same
class you should be treated you should
be able to use the same techniques the
same tools
that
the others are using uh
I I sort of agree with you on the
transfer of pricing it's something that
that that is has not been I say
challenged by this
State of New Hampshire
to try to bring
a more equalized approach to this but
it's more of a moral issue here the tax
policy should be
in a class should be the same and it's
not it's legal what what is being done
there is no question about that but by
the multinationals and there are
accounting departments and if you're a
an accountant you better be getting your
company the best deal they can get by
using the what is there I have no
problem with that but
those that are within there shouldn't be
excluded if just because they're
domestic
and
I find it very hard
to say that uh
the reason
they're paying more
in their tax liability is because
the others have been able to reduce
theirs with methods that the domestic
so
I think we can all stipulate the
transfer pricing exists
and transfer pricing is particularly
available when it comes to intangibles
like
patent writes and Licensing fees and and
so on and so forth it exists if you
study that subject you find that there's
a vast array
of perfectly normal customary sound
Business Pack practices to support
transfer pricing
and and to make sure that the costs of
having
[Music]
invested a huge amount on R D and and
developing protection and so on
is is shared across various entities so
Pharmaceuticals devised in the United
States that are later sold worldwide for
example
the question again unmeasurable
is to what extent have these transfer
pricing tools
been used in an abusive way abusive as
we might Define it being to minimize
taxes
um I think that the conundrum for any
state
especially this would be true for New
Hampshire if it's the first and only
state going back to worldwide combined
reporting
is that we don't have the the apparatus
of the federal tax code or the IRS
working with us
as Keen as pointed out starting point
for a BPT filing is the federal tax
return but the further that New
Hampshire Strays away from the federal
model the less that that's true the more
supplemental filings and and adjustments
have to be made
which again increases the audit of
Burden
so I think
if the this is not a preemption
um matter we we know that the federal
Congress has not preempted and that
legally we could do this if we thought
it was the right thing to do
but when you don't have the federal
government going down this
you got to ask yourself what are the
reasons why the federal government isn't
chasing
this Revenue quote left on the table in
the way that we're contemplating doing
it and and I think I think if you dig
into that what you find is that
the federal government isn't chasing
Revenue left on the table using this
particular method
but look what has happened there have
been International negotiations there is
a proposal that has not yet coalesced
to have a 15 worldwide minimum corporate
tax strong arguments in favor strong
arguments against but but that is
motivated in large part
for similar reasons
the
the night the 2017 tax cuts and jobs Act
included a number of steps it
implemented the guilty that we've been
talking about over again
it includes beat base erosion and
anti-abuse tax
it included the mandatory repatriation
tax
and here we sit in New Hampshire having
gone to single sales Factor but we also
tax guilty relative to the other states
aggressively at 50 percent
and and simultaneously we tax the
foreign dividend sources
so there are a whole array
of different efforts
to try and mitigate against the tendency
that might exist to use transfer pricing
or abusive tax avoidance purposes
and I just I think we should take stock
of the various ways in which the federal
government has tried to move in this
direction and ask ourselves why did they
never take the date to go to worldwide
just a little counter yes absolutely I I
called for a robust discussion today so
let's have it we've asked the question
you know why
did our government why has it not
well it's the one that initiated it
by the secret agreement between Margaret
Thatcher and President Reagan at the
White House and you did receive that
study
uh
in your can I just clarify that
the
yeah
this is the secret I I just want to make
sure that we're characterizing this
letter correctly I've read it so the
letter from Ronald Reagan to Margaret
Thatcher
says we're going to create a worldwide
unitary tax working group
to try to persuade the state's not to
implement
worldwide combined reporting
but rather at most
to adopt the water's edge limit
so the secret agreement is as you're
characterizing it is just simply a
letter
that says
the U.S government is not going to
implement uh combined worldwide
reporting and we're going to dissuade
any of the States from doing it and
we're going to ask those states that
have adopted it to unwind it and they
succeeded
promises that the federal government
would assist the States
with their
ability to get the information they need
for their tax policies and the working
group did not come down and apply that
to the state of New Hampshire can can
you elaborate on what those promises
were
I'm sorry I'm the one what the promises
that's in my
yes representative Valerie
just one word Secret
everything every president does a secret
well for 20 years all right so uh but
point is the federal government wanted
to change because of outside influences
not within the country but outside the
foreign Nationals wanted some change to
protect
a certain party in England in their
Investments
that go throughout the world
the royalty
the king and queen of England and that
was a start
and
I think that we have put ourselves in a
position because of
political I don't want to say this
political promises that that maybe would
come down the line if State of New
Hampshire were to step away from
worldwide reporting to various political
individuals that were in the state at
the time
I think there were future
possibility of positions within the
federal government
which a uh coroner office was looking at
to try to uh
yes to try to
make sure that
this was passed
and
in my study that I did and wrote about
the the
dra came forth and pushed this
as the
force that needed to say we needed a
change
and
it was not something that
the
Ways and Means Committee at the time was
looking to enact
there was a question by uh the
representative Jones I believe Robert
Jones that said
we want to get the tax that is required
no more no less
but he worried about the
constitutionality of it and then the
corner office came in and said we need
to do this we need to do this for the
State of New Hampshire to get
Investments and things we were getting
Investments
it's just a a political approach that
someone made a promise to somebody else
and that's the reason we're at this
position now that I have brought this
back to try to get a fair level of time
ironically I was actually involved
um yes so in 1993 as an associate
attorney with Wilmer Cutler and
Pickering I
became a
admitted to the Supreme Court bar and
participated in writing an amicus carry
a brief
in the case that went to the Supreme
Court on this subject and
there is no question whatsoever if you
go back and look through the record that
Congress
did not want a federal
combined worldwide reporting law and the
question of preemption that was framed
in the case was whether the Commerce
Clause somehow preempted California from
implementing worldwide combined
reporting even though Congress had not
taken affirmative action
and the Supreme Court determined that it
was not and the California was free to
go ahead so the irony
is that
just after the Supreme Court
cleared the path for California to
implement combined World reporting there
was a sea change on the policy side
and all of the states largely
participating in the worldwide unitary
tax working group
which included
[Music]
you know quite an array in
a State Legislative representative some
Governors and so on there was a sea
change back away from it so very very
ironic it's an unusual example of the
Supreme Court
clear something that's controversial
and no sooner is the ink dry then the
states start pulling back including New
Hampshire
so I think that the notion that there
was just a political agreement to
appease Britain
um
misses the overwhelming scene that was
well the the former commissioner Lloyd
Price at the time and then Everett
Taylor who was the dra commissioner at
that time
the price says
he stated that in his administration now
in 1986 he was not the commissioner
anymore he was I don't know where he was
moved to but he was not the commissioner
because in 1983 he wrote some statements
that
he would not step away from worldwide
reporting but he testified that the
administration right or wrong or
indifferent never his administration
didn't
never did go totally worldwide we never
did foreign tax dividends from foreign
parents I mean we never taxed foreign
parents okay even though California did
he added that if he were a tax
administrator in a business he would
make sure I shift all of the income and
profits to the foreign parents we know
as we sit in this room there are certain
corporations who shift their income to
states that do not and this at the time
to states that do not have a business
tax
and then ever Terror Taylor followed up
with he agreed with the testimony and
that if you do anything other than
unitary in the state of New Hampshire
you're going to destroy the tax base he
said he believed that the business
Community would probably want to go to
single accounting if you do that there
is going to be an awful lot of profit
being siphoned out of the state
we had experts that were trying to tell
us back then that
there is
Revenue
being siphoned out of this state
I I believe that
political pressure was still very strong
then
on why they came to go into
Water's Edge
so it's a 40 nearly 40 year old
discussion and I would stipulate that
if if we're ready to acknowledge that
there is revenue given away it still
begs the question
whether it's sufficient enough
that it's worth
the becoming an outlier
running our tax system differently than
any other state or the federal
government or the rest of the world
and enduring the complexity and the
burden of enforcing it
that's I think the question that this
I do not argue that point with you I
just argue that our taxes tax policy
should be Fern level
it should be equal for all those that
are in that class
and I think it's it's a moral decision
that we are going to have to make on
as you have told me the in the past
representative alray we don't pick
winners or losers but someone picked
winners and decided the other group was
so question
um by the way
all members please put your hand up as
soon as you've got something interject
I'm not trying to dominate
I've seen so far apart on regular Ways
and Means
[Laughter]
um
I think it's a huge question even if you
stipulate
that transfer pricing
is used
to reduce tax
and that there are ways in which that's
done that might be regarded as abusive
and might be regarded as coming at the
expense of the State of New Hampshire
for sake of discussion let's just assume
that that's true
I don't see that worldwide combined
reporting
so let's just say that I'm the CEO of a
multinational corporation that has well
the one I used to work at I was not CEO
but we were in 76 countries
so
you're you're in 76 countries and
um
you know maybe you register your ship in
Singapore or Panama
and maybe you have certain marketing
operations out of Bermuda maybe you do
these things because you you're running
a massive complex conglomerate
you're not necessarily doing them with
the United States on taxes specifically
in mind
you got to pay taxes in 76 countries and
you're certainly not doing it with New
Hampshire in mind and and I don't think
the corporation I worked for was
especially complex in the in the realm
of large multinationals
so how does
reporting the net income of 76 countries
do anything to address the question of
transfer pricing
to a so-called tax Haven Country which
might have been one or two or three out
of the 76. I I I just don't even see how
combined reporting if it was you know
implemented
and if it went
smoothly without too much of an audit I
still don't see how it recovers
the impact of transfer pricing that one
might characterize as abusive
and I think if you go through those tax
Foundation articles
you'll see that it's going to be a real
crap shoot whether in a particular
instance for a particular corporation in
a given Year New Hampshire gets more or
less Mr Speaker
if I can address that and Matt I'm sure
will correct me if I'm a little off here
but when you would have a common a
combining of entities the related party
transactions are usually removed during
the combined reporting so simply stated
if you have a New Hampshire company
that's paying a million dollars to a UK
company for royalties or whatever
and those uh entity information is then
combined there would be an eliminating
entry to remove the transfer pricing
cost to New Hampshire and the income at
the UK level so the transfer pricing
activity I'm presuming would largely go
away as a factor here makes sense it
neutralizes it becomes a wash and then
it what comes into play Then is the
apportionment issue which is how much
were sales and uh as you were talking
you made me think of another level of
complexity relative to sales we've
recently moved to single sales a few
years ago we've more recently moved to
Market based sourcing which simply
stated is a theory in which instead of
the cost of performance which is where
people are doing the work the sale is
allocated to the state or in this case
potentially the foreign entity where
the benefit of the service or the item
is received and this gets very very
complex many states have moved over to
this in New Hampshire recently took it
on in 2022 I think is when it was
implemented 22 21 21 thank you I better
go back and get my 21 returns one year
before the single sales fact
um that's right so um
that's very complex especially when you
get into say intangible items or where
who the benefit who's receiving the
benefit where is the that place which
again not only complicates it but in
trying to identify is New Hampshire
um is it New Hampshire that is receiving
the benefit of this it's possible that
it would further dilute increase the
denominator or dilute the new the
numerator for New Hampshire because
maybe it's the and I don't really know
how it would work in theory but a I
think it's more complex but I think
potentially for these foreign countries
especially the ones that are foreign
foreign entities that own U.S companies
you might say well the benefit is
received entirely overseas for
market-based sourcing when that is
applicable which again means that New
Hampshire is actually maybe losing that
some of that U.S revenue and I have no
idea where the numbers would fall but I
certainly think it's something to
consider in the process of of another
unknown well
really great comments and I think you're
you're highlighting another thing that
we need to really pay attention to and
that is the law and the climate in so
many ways is different today than it was
in 1980 or 1986 the last time that the
state made decisions on this subject
implementing and repealing
um
so
the Advent of the BET and the credit the
single sales the market-based sourcing
uh the taxing of guilty the the federal
scheme for for all of this international
relations and in proposals that uh you
know are still being discussed I think
another thing that we should take
stock of is the fact that if the
assumption is that businesses are
incentivized to move profits away from a
higher tax country then it makes a
difference what is evolving on the tax
rate side and so in 2017 uh the tax cuts
and jobs act reduced the maximum
corporate
um
tax rate from 35 to 21. that's a big
deal
and at the same time the state of New
Hampshire through a series of increments
has reduced our BPT from eight and a
half to seven and a half percent we've
simultaneously been reducing the the
business Enterprise tax rates so when
you
when you see tax rates coming down that
mitigate the margin that theoretically
is being exploited you've got some
reason to think that the problem itself
yes Mr pulley
clarification like so
if you had your 76 countries and
companies and were worried about
transfer pricing abuse to a Cayman tub
or another low tax which is more
infrequent now as you mentioned because
of rate reduction in the U.S right
um
if this is a U.S multinational those 76
companies again are
put together in part of guilty which is
already in the New Hampshire tax base
now there is a a hurdle level called 10
percent of qualified business asset
investment whatever it is Qi
um and then there's the 50 reduction and
the apportionment that we've already
heard about so those are tweaks where if
you're worried about the fairness of it
it's already in the base in one form or
another it's just taxation allows for
these other things that may be deemed
dilutive or not fair but they're in the
base
right so I just wanted to highlight that
fact we've had a concept of transfer
pricing creating base erosion right as
compared to it's in the base it's just
how they the state's chosen to tax it
and I think the cost analysis was pretty
interesting just to see New Hampshire's
taxation of foreign income compared to
other states where it's it's high right
I mean just on
on that analysis so I just want to
highlight that where you were mentioning
the 76 companies where it's in the base
through that mechanism and that's the
intention of it when you think of guilty
is to try to uh kind of mitigate that
kind of offshorem of profits federally
they're you know there's different
there's tax credits as well that can
soften that and all that but the state
right and I I
thank you good points I think the fact
that the federal government deals with
taxation
um
assessed and paid in other countries
through credits
whereas the state of New Hampshire
deals with
um the uncertainties where revenue is
derived through formulary apportionment
representative schamberger
are you hesitating I'm hesitating I just
uh
when you want the term transfer pricing
there's another part of that that should
be an arm's length approach that the
federal government has stated and too
much of that
is not
separate it's it's not like
the chair and I if we each had a company
and were separate we could negotiate and
say okay I'll charge you this and that
but
a unitary company that
the chair has
himself the senator you you
could you Mr Kennedy could say or Mr
Foley could see
uh even though representative Schamberg
would only charge you ten dollars we're
going to charge you a hundred dollars
and you'll be able to take that
and reduce your
tax liability when you when you file
your paperwork
and I realized guilty but it's only on
U.S
based National
part of this we're not making we're not
including the foreign Nationals
multinationals in this
back to that tournament we were making
that distinction before
correct me if I'm wrong
we are including the us-based subsidiary
and activity of the foreign
multinational Enterprise
we're not including their
non-nexus
foreign activities
and that's true for guilty too
yeah so it's
correct and so
um and where it's interesting so I've
worked with with many clients more on
the smaller side
um purposely right that's the space I
want to play in but there's two classes
I encounter a lot from a foreign side
just to highlight uh it one one is I
like the US market I'd like to start
sales in New Hampshire seems nice I
vacationed there once when I was a kid
what have you it's strange how these
decisions are made right this that the
other thing and I'm going to establish a
subsidiary there and start hiring there
so in the relative scheme of The Wider
business it's it's kind of small it's a
sales Venture right that's what they're
doing the other common one that I
encounter and there's obviously large
big big ones and we can talk about that
but
um is
um entities that are looking to raise
Capital here in the states and so they
actually do an anti-inversion right we
think of inversions us going forward
they go foreign and become U.S parented
because that's how they can get
investment here in the states
um so it's it's funny as we've talked
about all these things pushing things
out I just want to highlight you know
those are the two experiences I'm seeing
so so for example this would be a way of
getting listed on the New York Stock
exchanger
stock exchanger or um become attractive
to the PE or VC funds that are here
generally one of the conversations when
we get to these kind of accelerators and
whatnot is
how are you going to become a domestic a
U.S company Because unless you're a real
rocket ship and a standout usually
they'll pass on that investment
without it being a us-based company so
it's it's kind of interesting just in
that regard
very interesting
um
are we out of pause
I would just I think it's worth uh
taking note Meredith Beeson who was with
us last Monday
uh has been tuning in and and heard our
questions about the Minnesota and Maine
and has done a little research which uh
I'll take this as good information
unless someone comes up with something
different you know I'll just read it to
you the Minnesota house tax committee
heard hf2883 a worldwide combined
reporting Bill and then it was inserted
into an Omnibus tax bill HF 1938 this
included numerous other proposed tax
policy changes and was passed by the
house the issue was never introduced or
even discussed in Senate committees as a
standalone Bill like it was on the house
side the mandatory worldwide combined
reporting provision with nhf 1938 was
then removed during negotiations by
House and Senate tax committee members
before the final passage of this Omnibus
tax bill well we not we all know how
those Dynamics work
uh in Maine
LD 428 commissioned main Revenue
Services should do a fur a study to
further look at worldwide and the state
released their report in February there
has been no further discussion on the
issue this year
so we might want to I don't think I've
seen it yet we might want to get a hold
so I you know I I think
um
I think that the presenters paired us to
see both sides of the question
and uh in the colloquy here between
representative Schamberg and myself
and all the comments I think we've
pretty much put the issue up on the
table
I think we we may need to tease things
out for a uh
um you know for a report for for
adequately explaining
inclusions but
we pretty much know now what I think
we're going to know in the time frame
that we file this report
I guess my question is at least
tentatively
um
is this a good time for us to each give
an indication for where we think we
should go so we can see how it is that
we're going to draft this report
um yes Senator Murphy I wonder oh I'm
sorry okay sure
um before we get to that I wonder if we
might just hit the bullets relative to
some uh items that are generally
accepted as as you know base and I don't
mean take a long time and then some of
those things for and against so that
because I think there are some things
that we haven't discussed today that
were mentioned before
um but perhaps they were but I remember
um there was a reference to re
retaliation of other countries and we've
sort of touched base on that and New
Hampshire being an outlier that we've
also touched base on that but I was kind
of looking to just summarize the bullets
to make sure that I sure why don't you
take a stab at that all right um so
relative to what I I think we've all
decided as as understood is that moving
to worldwide reporting is not a
constitutional issue that the Supreme
Court has determined that would be
allowed that transfer pricing exists
um and likely or probably means that
revenue is being siphoned away from the
state because of transfer pricing
um
uh
and that New Hampshire uh doesn't
currently tax guilty which is somewhat
unique and probably likely includes some
ability to tax
does tax guilty does tax guilty so those
things we all kind of under understand
relative to the arguments against
um there's an indication that this would
make New Hampshire an outlier relative
to the tech moving to worldwide
reporting we have concern of retaliation
of other countries which may include
losing local businesses
um it would be more burdensome for both
practitioners for businesses and the New
Hampshire dra relative to compliance and
audit
um
and again the argument against is that
that New Hampshire does already tax uh
guilty and foreign income is already
included at some level rather to foreign
dividends or guilty income
um the four
would be that largely that there appears
to be because of the transfer pricing
that there is an inequity between
domestic New Hampshire companies and
foreign companies
um that uh this would address the
transfer pricing issue to make things
more Equitable
um
and in theory keep profit within New
Hampshire on again on a theoretical
basis and I'm sorry one and some some
general items of just data is it's
unknown what the revenue results would
be what the effect in terms of how this
also plays with guilty
potentially there are alternatives
instead of going to worldwide reporting
to address the transfer pricing issue
um and we don't know in terms of the
revenues results we don't know how the
denominator would change
relative to now having to a portion out
of New Hampshire
so those are the bullets that I have and
I'd be very interested if anybody else
has any bullets beyond what I just
identified
I thank you very much I think that's
helpful I'll just make a comment that uh
regardless of where we land on our
recommendation I want to make sure that
our report is a full disclosure document
and so you know acknowledging uh the
pros and the cons I think is part of our
duty uh in reporting and uh you know so
for example if we recommend against it
we still need to give the reasons why
its proponents uh thought it would be
worthwhile
yes representative Ellery yeah to
exactly that end and and thank you for
coming up with those points at
it's a pretty good start it
matter of fact is an excellent start
um however with your second Point uh
regarding uh transfer pricing exists but
we've also heard that we don't know that
it exists we're presuming that it exists
based upon corporate behaviors
how do we
get that
nuanced in there
so even if we stipulate there's an
yeah
that's that affects two different issues
on that I I that that's that's a
language issue and we're not just
writing this for economists with all due
regard but we're also writing it for the
common guy that sits in the house of 400
people over there with a wide
variety of experience
uh so which leads to my second question
we need to define the term denominator
wow
you guys know what it is
let's it has to be
the language needs to be as to what it
is I I think that's that's correct I
would agree with that I would like to
report
to include a description of what it
actually means
to combine all worldwide uh entities and
what gets swept into the equation as a
result of it
and
how does that affect the
the resulting dilution in that same
formula of the New Hampshire activity
you know something that may be
um for one out of 50 states right that's
two percent
I was reading some program uh within the
last two years where I saw that the New
Hampshire share based on you know
population and so on of some federal
large s was 0.34 percent
so if if if a very large corporation
doing business in all 50 states has for
sake of discussion
0.34 percent of their activity in the
state of New Hampshire and they also
happen to be multinational
what percentage of this Revenue were
forcing them to report
will actually be attributed to New
Hampshire I mean it it it I won't say
negligible that it's a very small
percent
um I I think one of the things I'd like
to include you know when we're doing the
pros and cons is
um mitigating factors specifically
taking note of those changes in federal
and state law since the 1980s
that um
you know at least potentially have uh
have mitigated the issue
so we've I don't need to re-list them
but all those things having to do with
the rate and uh and and what we're
um I can put my list together and send
it off Absolutely I'll send it to
well yes I'll chime in
um you know I don't think it was clear
to me today until today
Mr chairman the disadvantage I was at on
this committee in terms of background
and knowledge
um I have read everything provided I've
watched either in person or recorded
every speaker
but
you wrote an amicus brief on this issue
is clearly a matter of passion and
commitment for the published author
representative Schaumburg
Keen is the
a gentleman who makes Mr Mr Foley makes
his living as an accountant
um
and Mr Foley you were on this committee
last year as a as an accountant and
Mr Kennedy was the Bia yes
any case
so I had the most amount of sort of
catching up to do I think
and perhaps it would be
my only thing I can bring to the table
is sort of a fresh face approach to it
because
as familiar as you all are with this
topic matter topic I was not and
despite having served some terms on
house Ways and Means and I'll Senate
Ways and Means and having a basic
understanding of business Taxation and
state law regarding this
um
I knew very little about the concept of
unitary worldwide taxation
before I walked into the room the first
time
but you asked where we think we're
coming down and I can only speak to
myself in that matter
I think the cost of compliance I've been
convinced the cost of compliance would
be inordinarily huge
I don't think there's any chance the
cost of compliance
is going to be offset by whatever
Revenue
we may or may not gain as a result of
adopting this
um
I'm also hesitant to embrace
increasing cost on these corporations
because as we all know all costs we
apply to corporations are passed on to
Consumers at the end
I think it'd be a potentially a
disadvantage for New Hampshire
companies
and discourage future activity by those
and I have to say you know we all come
at this from our own philosophical and
political backgrounds and viewpoints
I kept seeing Delaware and South Dakota
mentioned
and I suspect that different people look
at those
those States and think different things
my my reaction was why relating them
have all the fun
[Laughter]
maybe there's some lessons there for us
but that's my Approach and I I also
think just in conclusion that one of the
big advantages of our tax system is that
it's simple in New Hampshire our
corporate taxes are simple and I say
that as somebody who actually files them
every year
it's like usually is a
single piece of paper double-sided for
my companies
and I would be hesitant to
um
make that immensely more complicated I
think it's the cost compliance right now
is very low and it should stay that way
so you asked where I where we would
stand I'm coming down against it myself
thank you
thank you great comments and
thanks for taking the First Leap
oh Senator Murphy uh
sat near me several years while I was in
the house and uh
set here on Ways and Means at the same
time
um
he's expressed several points that I
concur
pretty strongly with this America
particularly the fact this whenever you
start attacking
the ability of an Enterprise to
earn a living for itself and pay back
its investors
and then also grow which then provides
jobs is a tax on people
because the only people that pay taxes
are people not corporations that's
something we need to
sometimes gets lost in the mix of
numbers
thank you
now I I'm looking at Keane Keane and I
had a brief conversation before we began
and of course it's the position of the
dra to remain neutral so uh that puts
Keen in an interesting position as a
voting member and all that Keen explain
uh how he intends to navigate that
that is correct so uh the DIA remains
neutral on this uh on this issue and the
dra will do its level best whether the
uh finally if the the commission or the
legislation decides to
go worldwide or maintain Warriors age we
will continue to do our function
um as the revenue administration of New
Hampshire uh and with that said we are
so if there were things that had to do
with procedure and so on you might weigh
in but as to the pro and con on the
bottom line issue
um yeah that's very much understood
yes
um I saw that light on so well oh gosh I
should have turned that off a while ago
so
I I guess to to qualify I'm also
somewhat neutral except to the extent
that
um to me there's just a too many
variables and an unknown which is
concerning
um I think the things that come to mind
though I certainly do appreciate wanting
to make the playing field Equitable and
even and I'm just not sure that from the
information that's been provided that we
have enough information to know that
moving to worldwide reporting would
actually do that given that New
Hampshire does tax the guilty tax given
we don't know what the denominator would
look like relative to the numbers
um and I believe there are too many
unknowns this in conjunction with
um I'm again I appreciate that we'd like
the playing field to be Equitable but I
don't actually see the direct benefit to
smaller businesses right now if there
was something that we felt that okay
well now that we have more revenues
coming in so the rate is going to go
down or something but with all of those
things and lastly the idea that maybe
there is an alternative to addressing
the transfer pricing rules which we
haven't which is not a bill or anything
um that those factors kind of guide me
to say that the complexity of moving to
worldwide reporting
um it might produce a benefit but it's
it's probably just not at this none is
very good weighing of the factors
Mr Foley
I I should have asked before to the
society I assume I'm neutral here which
I think would be our stance you probably
know
um but it's certainly uh I think
everything said
preceding me kind of covers the facts
and it's certainly an interesting
quandary that's been wrestled since the
80s right in the enhancements in 482
which is the transfer pricing code and
the cross-border litigation and having
worked on those projects which we
luckily haven't gotten too far into
it's certainly an interesting space in a
space that's been scrutinized and will
continue to be and I think this has been
an interesting part of that so okay
representative Schamberg I guess I'm
well
I will probably be on the minority end
of this okay
on this commission you know
probably require that uh
require a moral responsibility and a
political responsibility
we can't separate political we can't
separate them more even though
we know that
this was done for the benefit of the
foreign
multinationals and
by saying that I go to the only
Authority that has stated it back in
1999 and that was a New Hampshire
Supreme Court
stated that this bill this law Waters
Edge was drafted it was presented for
the benefit of foreign multinationals
and no one has taken up that cause since
1999.
uh
so I think what you're going to see
though is that
I will write
a piece my report will be
for the passage of this that'll be my
recommendation because I believe that
when you have a highest Authority in the
land in the state of New Hampshire see
this is
something that should be addressed and
it was never addressed even from 1999
onward I don't know
why someone hasn't addressed it but
I am for it so
okay
you stand in your ground
um so I'll give you my views
um and much of what I believe has
already been said so I won't repeat
everything
but
I wouldn't deny
the potential for transfer pricing to be
used for tax minimization in ways that
cost New Hampshire money
I would stipulate to that
I would just simply use that Point of
Departure to make the comment that it's
unmeasurable and inherently speculative
and there are plenty of reasons to
believe that it's not huge that it's
nowhere near 177 million dollars
but again I'm speculating even when I
I think that the costs the policy costs
of having New Hampshire Venture into uh
you know territory all of its own
um in this case are potentially quite
great uh I'm not an apologist for New
Hampshire I'm perfectly happy that we do
many things in our own way here
including the BPT and bet
um I'm perfectly comfortable with the
fact that we reached our own conclusions
on how to deal with guilty and uh and
foreign dividend income but I believe
that when you take stock of all of the
legal changes both at the national level
and at the state level over the 40 years
the discussions and the relative merits
have shifted and we're not in the same
evaluative equation that we would have
been if this was 1987 or 88 and we were
considering flipping back
so I I think that the
the fundamental challenges
or the tax filers as well as for the
administration for the dra
are Monumental and I have a much easier
ability to if not quantify to visualize
the cons the cons come across to me as
more extensive and more compelling than
the pros the pros I wouldn't deny them
but they're too theoretical to persuade
me
so I
I would take the view that this
commission make a recommendation to not
proceed
and and to specifically recommend two
house and to Senate ways and means that
this is not a scheme that we should
Implement in New Hampshire
um
so having said that
I think we have several members who are
kind of in the neutral area
and we have a proponent who wants to
make that case
and we have several of us who uh I think
have come down on the con side and maybe
it would be worthwhile
to have
three drafts
a a
Advocates draft which I would ask
representative Schamberg to to do
a
um opposing draft which unless somebody
else would like to uh jump in I'm
I've been I've been anticipating that
that Duty might fall on me yes I've got
notes
um and then I think it may be that even
the neutral
um parties uh have something to say in
terms of you know the pros and the cons
and the complications
um
and I think if we can
suss out
perhaps something that Mr Kennedy and Mr
Foley work on together
something that representative shamberg
prepares something that I prepare
um and circulate those prior to the 17th
we may be in a position on the 17th to
you know draw our conclusions and even
if they're editing that follows how does
so will you two gentlemen take that
assignment
yeah
I'm sorry what's what's coming to mind
is you you had mentioned that the
reports would weigh both the pros and
cons yes so I'm thinking more that
whatever we compile would maybe be
incorporated into uh your report as you
know I'm opposed but we recognize there
are pros and cons on both sides so I'm
not sure we would need a third report to
actually again yes I think I think
that's uh
very much as I think it would probably
uh unfold you know let's let me just say
that uh a personal perspective I hope I
but um
when a legislative body decides that
it's not appropriate to go forward with
something that doesn't always mean that
it's a terrible idea or that it's not at
least conceptually well founded it just
means that on the way to the pros and
the cons there's not a compelling enough
reason to proceed with it right and so
even a whole bunch of neutral commentary
essentially represents a lack of
conviction to go forward and we can see
how
what we've written melds together and
and I think you can certainly help
bolster whatever I draft in terms of
making sure that
the report recognizes all the relevant
yes representative Valerie
when you talk about three reports I I
don't necessarily see that as three
reports as much as three sections within
a report agreed and so there wouldn't be
a Minority Report as such but there
would be a contrarian opinion view which
Tom is very good at being a contrarian
yeah
at the same time the non-partial view
would probably be the Corpus of the the
report and the final conclusion would be
um
there's all sorts of stuff you make up
your own mind
uh to
in one way or another I'm reading that
correct Mr chair
yes I think very much
once we see the drafts we'll know how
well they fit but yes I I agree with you
and I think it's the commission's report
okay well we did
um I should have mentioned this at the
beginning we did make the decision to
live stream we know we have uh um people
who have tuned in and uh we are creating
a record on a very very uh complicated
subject matter that hasn't been
Revisited this seriously in decades
so it's also good that we have a
recorded uh you know view of this I I
know I'm going to go back and tune into
the summaries here and make sure that I
so thank you and unless there's anything
anybody else wants to add I think it's
been a terrifically productive meeting I
look forward to getting back together in
time is 12
thank you oh thank you
I've learned to watch
probably more than any other commission